you are involved in the search for a
vaccine and how optimistic are you that
we'll find one and how long could that
take I'm optimistic science has moved on
in enormous ways over the last few years
and the ability to do the science do the
research do the development and the
manufacturing is incomparable to what it
was even say ten years ago but the truth
is we don't have another vaccine for any
other human coronaviruses common cold
SARS MERS and so that it's not a given
that we will make a vaccine I would be
optimistic but it's not whether it's a
vaccine or a treatments or a test or a
Diagnostics the truth is we have to do
all of these and we have to do all of
them in parallel because we're not sure
which one of these will work and in the
end actually we need all of those and so
the investment now in the science the
research the development but also making
sure now that we're thinking about how
do we manufacture it because if we did
have a vaccine let's say late in 2020 or
into 2021 we would then need to
manufacture it in billions of doses and
make those billions of doses available
to the world so just having a vaccine
that is safe and effective
proven is not enough we have to think
all the way through to the end of how we
get this around the world because if
there is any country vulnerable if there
is any country where there is still
transmission of this virus then in fact
every country is vulnerable and so it
needs all of us to come together from
industry from governments from
philanthropy from science to come
together to make sure this can be done
and done as quickly as we possibly can
which I hope we would have a vaccine to
towards the end of this year but that's
a vaccine in a vial it's a vaccine that
we believe to be safe vaccine that we
think might be effective that's not
having a Maxine for the world I'm
interested in so you hope that they
could be won by the end of this year
scientists at Oxford Union University
say they're hoping to have a million
doses of a vaccine by September I mean
that does seem to be on a slightly
different timeframe to many other people
I've spoken to who say you know a
vaccine could be 18 months away do you
think that's realistic
I think it's realistic that we will have
vaccines that we have been into people
already on the beginning of May the
first vaccine in a
America was administered to somebody a
healthy volunteer to see if it was safe
we so we have a vaccine in a sense now
we don't know if it's effective we don't
know how safe it is and wheats not
manufactured at any scale but that does
take time to prove both safety and it's
critical vaccines are given to healthy
people we must make sure they are safe
and we must make sure they're effective
and they would protect somebody from
being infected so I think it's just
crucial to realize having a vaccine in
itself in say a million doses which you
know to be safe and you believe to be
effective that is not the end game the
end game is ensure that it is truly
effective it's effective in the elderly
it's effective in young children it's
effective and right across the age group
in all in all populations and then you
have a factor that in billions of doses
to administer them to the world and then
you actually have to get that vaccine to
people wherever they are leaving nobody
behind that is an enormous scientific
challenge it's also an enormous
logistics and delivery challenge and I
just want to pick up on something you
said and your first answer which is it's
not given but we might even be able to
get a vaccine for life at 19 the World
Health Organization has said there's
currently no evidence that people who've
recovered from coronavirus have immunity
and we've also seen of course those
cases in South Korea where people that
have seemingly recovered from cope at 19
and then test positive again are you
worried that we might not get immunity
I'm worried on so many levels with this
is a completely new infection prior to
some point in December that humanity had
never seen this virus before so we're
learning all about it all of the time do
people when they recover from the
infection do they develop immunity do
does that protect them against getting a
second infection how long does that
immunity last is the immunity the same
in children as in adults is it the same
in senior individuals we're learning all
of this all the time what is clear
though is that after you are infected
majority people actually do make what we
call antibodies which we believe are
really important for infection most
people by about a month after infection
do have antibodies which we think would
be important
in protecting them against the future if
that's true then the possibility of
making a vaccine I would be more
optimistic yes how long it will last
does it last one year three years do we
have to revaccinated period of time
those are all things which science just
can't tell us at the moment but
absolutely critical questions and how
what does that mean as well for antibody
tests I mean many people saw this as a
potential way out of a lockdown but if
the whole of immunity or how long
immunity lasts for is under question is
that idea now really for the birds no
it's not for the birds
the antibody tests done through a
laboratory by a laboratory test called
called analyzer those I believe are now
increasingly robust they can be trusted
to be sure you're identifying somebody
that has been infected and you can be
sure that somebody who does not have
antibodies that's not being protected at
about a month or thereafter we must
learn how long those antibodies last did
they last three months they may last six
months are they still there five years
later and of course at the moment only
four months into this pandemic we don't
know the answers to those questions the
rapid diagnostic tests which have been
talked about a lot in my view none of
those rapid diagnostic tests today are
good enough to be used to inform
individuals about their risks or whether
they've got antibodies whether they can
go back to work those rapid tests are
just not good enough at the moment to be
able to inform individual decisions and
they're not really good enough to tell
us the number event the amount of
antibodies in the population at large so
we are reliant on the test for the virus
done by a PCR that's for a virus and
with reliance on a test in a laboratory
called analyzer to measure those
antibodies okay now and every tragically
high number of people are still of
course dying of code 19 but there is
some evidence that the number is
stabilizing even that the number of
people in critical care in hospital beds
is even starting to come down do you
believe we may be past the pig yes of
this first wave oh we should not see
this as a discrete episode I think the
probability is what we must be planning
for is that there would be further waves
of this in the future but for this first
wave
I think the number of new infections
stabilized maybe we could so ago the
number of hospitalizations maybe a week
or so ago and yes tragically there are
still far too many people dying but the
number of people dying in this country
and actually in many countries of the
world is now either stabilizing or
starting to come down that is good news
it's it's we're probably just that past
the peak in many parts of this country
as it's true in many parts of the world
and we will come off that peak and the
numbers will will reduce but that has
only happened because of the public's
respect for and following of the advice
around the social distancing and the
lockdowns if we were to release those
lockdowns too soon whilst the infection
rates are still high and there are still
people in the community who've got
infected then the epidemic would come
back again it would come back very
quickly it would rebound within a few
weeks or a couple of months and so it's
critical that people aren't people are
the public is really respecting the
advice and it is that that has driven
the change in numbers these things don't
happen by chance they happen because
what we're all doing and the public
deserve great thanks and respect for
that it has made a huge difference so
with all that in mind when do you think
some of the looked on measures could
start to be eased we've seen lots
reports for example suggesting that it
could be as early as mid-may yeah it
depends on it really depends on the data
it's impossible today to give a date in
fact what is most important is that you
see from data not just plucking figures
from the sky you see data that suggests
the number of infections are now below a
certain level the number of people in
hospital below a certain level health
care workers are protected and we know
that the NHS has got the capacity to
deal with any rebound if it came
critically though the circulation in the
community the circulation in care homes
that was on earlier on your program and
of course the the circulation that is
going on still in hospitals those all
have to come down dramatically further
than they are today
I would hope they will get there in
three four weeks time because it's clear
that the lockdown can't go on much
longer the Dane the damage it's doing to
all of our health our well-being our
mental health
it's disproportionately of course
affecting the most vulnerable and the
least able to with resilience in society
that's a really big issue of inequality
the lockdown is damaging business and
ultimately that's damaging all of our
lives so the lock downs cannot go on
forever and we must lift them as soon as
we can but we can't lift them too soon
and we can't just make arbitrary dates
and say it'll be a date in in May that
is plucked from the sky now it has to be
driven on a crane by the data and the
data will come clear over the next one
two and three weeks and the huge amount
of effort is going on to make sure that
data is available okay now when I spoke
to Michael gave a little bit earlier on
the program and was talking about the UK
government's response I put it to him
not on things such as testing on a
protective equipment the government
seems to have been slower than other
countries in gearing up and of course
hindsight is a wonderful thing but do
you think that the UK has been a bit
flat-footed in responding to you over 19
particularly when you compare it to
other countries perhaps with more
experience of dealing with these kind of
respiratory pandemics yeah I think the
will there must be lessons learnt and
the must be lessons learnt of course in
comparison to other countries you your
your point at the end there about
experience of epidemics and pandemics I
think is a really important one I think
Korea has done an amazing job so far but
let us just wait until to see the whole
pandemic passed through but but Korea
has at the moment done a fantastic job
as have Singapore and both of those
countries in the last few years did
suffer from really quite devastating
epidemics Singapore suffered very badly
from SARS in 2002-2003 Korea had a very
nasty outbreak of Middle East
respiratory syndrome MERS just a few
years ago when one person flew into
Seoul and infected about 200 other
people including in the hospital and
clinic environment so they reformed
their public health system Lee they put
in place measures that would allow them
to respond much quicker and I think
you're now seeing the benefits of that
preparation it all comes back in the end
to investment in public health public
health is something you often don't see
it prevents things or rather than
reacting to them it keeps us all healthy
without as
really ever giving the credit it
deserves and what you see if you if you
don't invest in public health and
frankly most countries around the world
do not invest in public health enough
then you see when you're stretched when
you're stressed when epidemics come and
that the unexpected happens there is not
that spare capacity in order to respond
in in ways that Singapore and career
after the epidemics they suffered in
recent years were able to reinvest in
those and in the end that's what counts
the Sunday Times this morning claims
over five lost weeks at the beginning of
the year when Boris Johnson wasn't
attending every Cobra meeting that when
the UK wasn't listening to the warnings
from scientists and looking to what was
happening elsewhere and trying to ramp
up testing capacity are trying to bring
in protective equipment were we to slow
in those early months yeah these lessons
will be learned I think that the in
relation to testing yes if you look at
what was happening in Korea and
Singapore and indeed in Germany there
was a much quicker ramping up of tests
it's critical testing will be critical
as we come out of this epidemic testing
and isolation as advised by the whu-oh
is actually at the heart of every public
health response testing isolation
looking after the vulnerable making sure
you've got clinical capacity to look
after those that inevitably do get sick
as well as the development of
Diagnostics treatment and vaccines but
the ramping up of testing the provision
of PPE in hospitals to protect health
care workers all of these in in
retrospect yes should have happened
earlier I've worked in emerging
infections for 20 years now living in in
Vietnam and the key is you've got to
move faster than the pace of the
academic you can't be complacent you
cannot think that we're doing well
because we're going faster than we
usually do if that is slower than the
pace of the epidemic itself you will
fall behind and when the epidemic is is
going at its fastest falling behind you
never actually catch up or you don't
catch up for many weeks and I think that
for me is the lesson that must be
learned you have to go faster than the
epidemic itself not just pretend that
you're going quicker than you usually do
it's all dependent on the epic
threat that you face not some arbitrary
other situation